formation âgé graphique et sociales
sixième année aujourd'hui l'aménagement
du territoire en wallonie dans notre
cour où nous allons aborder la question
de l'organisation spatiale l aménagement
du territoire la première question que
l'on doit se poser légitimement c'est
qui gère l'aménagement du territoire en
belgique et a fortiori en wallonie la
question de du qui s'occupe de quoi est
largement tributaire de la structure de
l'état dans lequel cette question se
pose
pour rappel il y à deux états possibles
n'est pas unitaire où il y a un seul
pouvoir le pouvoir central comme la
france où l'état est souverain et où il
ya bien sûr des niveaux de pouvoir
décentralisé mais qui reste soumis à cet
état central par exemple dans le cas de
la france nous avons bien sûr l'état qui
est représenté par le président de la
république et par le premier ministre
est en dessous duquel bien sûr on aura
d'autres structures de pouvoir comme les
régions les départements et les
municipalités
certains pays sont des états fédéraux
séquelles la maille des états unis ou de
la belgique
c'est à dire que l'état va avoir
certaines compétences toujours en larmes
et la justice et affaires étrangères
sont des pros relatifs qui sont
réservées à l'état mais d'autres
composantes vont venir également exercer
certaines compétences et ce sur le même
pied d'égalité que par rapport à cet
état central exemple en belgique les
régions où les länder d'allemagne ont
d'autres compétences pour lesquels
l'état n'a aucun mot à dire ce sont les
régions qui vont exercer pleinement ses
compétences
on a donc l'état fédéral qui composait
d'un état central et qui est mis sur le
même pied d'égalité que les régions par
exemple où les länder le tableau suivant
reprend la structure de l'état fédéral
belge
nous avons bien sûr l'état fédéral qui
va
versée par exemple la justice les
compétences de justice des affaires
étrangères ar mais nous avons les
communautés et les régions
ces trois structures sont sur albi
d'égalité bien sûr chacune de ces
structures à un pouvoir législatif et le
pouvoir exécutif qui vont se compléter
en dessous de ce ca en dessous de cette
structure propre à l'état fédéral
devrait pouvoir ayant le même la même
compétence ont le même niveau de
compétence
nous allons avoir des pouvoirs
subordonnés il s'agit des provinces et
des communes ceux ci n'ont en fait que
les compétences qui leur sont attribués
par les autres niveaux tour et ils sont
toujours soumis à une tutelle
vous allez le lire dans cet organigramme
qui est un petit peu complexe où se
pratique où s'exerce la compétence de
l'aménagement du territoire très
précisément en wallonie ce sont les
régions et les communes qui vont exercer
ce pouvoir
sapphire sur votre attention évidemment
ce découpage entre les différents
niveaux de pouvoir que vous devez
maîtriser si vous êtes rapidement permis
donc évidemment pour les régions j'ai un
pouvoir législatif qui est le conseil
régional wallon où il ya des députés
wallons qui siègent et j'ai un pouvoir
exécutif c'est à dire le gouvernement où
elle rompt avec le ministre wallon de
l'aménagement du territoire carlo di
antonio au niveau des communes j'ai bien
sûr un conseil communal avec des
conseillers communaux et un collège
communal qui est composé du bourgmestre
et des échoppes ont résumé
qui sont les acteurs de l'aménagement du
territoire en volume au niveau régional
j'ai le gouvernement j'ai le ministre la
dg au cas ce qui en fait la direction
générale qui va être compétente pour les
questions d'aménagement du territoire
donc c'est en quelque sorte
l'administration
j'ai bien sûr tous les fonctionnaires
délégués qui vont assurer un suivi des
différents dossiers
et puis j'ai des instances d'avis qu'on
va consulter le cas échéant pour avoir
un avis extérieur comme par exemple le
conseil régional d'aménagement du
territoire au niveau communal j'aurai le
collège communal qu'on se composait des
échevins et bourgmestre
le conseil communal l'administration
communale c'est à dire les
fonctionnaires communaux qui vont faire
le suivi des dossiers et j'ai aussi une
instance des instances d'avis là quand
la commission consultative d'aménagement
du territoire la mobilité ccatm et bien
sûr les enquêtes publiques vous voyez
parfois certainement d'autres communes
des petits panneaux souvent sur fond
jaune à sanaa deux jaunes comme ça à vis
des organismes de ce sont ces enquêtes
publiques qui sont faites chaque fois
qu'il ya un projet d'urbanisme qui est
mieux
on va bien sûr en terme d'aménagement du
territoire avoir une règle générale
cette règle générale c'est dans le code
wallon d'aménagement du territoire de
l'urbanisme du patrimoine qui deviendra
prochainement
la cod tai chi et le code du
développement territorial
ça c'est un changement qui va s'opérer
d'ici la fin de l'année hans avaient été
prévues pour 2016
donc ça va être prochainement donc ça
c'est vraiment la loi le règlement c'est
pas le terme correct mais je me suis dit
ces mots là pour que ça soit clair pour
vous qui va vraiment gérer l'aménagement
du territoire angolais
à côté de ça j'ai le règlement communal
d'urbanisme qui est une règlement local
alors évidemment la région wallonne va
prendre des mesures pour un petit peu
coordonner toutes les actions en termes
d'aménagement du territoire et on va
aller à revoir donc des plans régionaux
vous voyez qu'en fonction je me situe en
région wallonne la région de bruxelles
capitale ou en flandre
j'aurai des règlements forcément
différent puisque c'est chaque région
fille décide pour son territoire ce
qu'elle veut chez nous le grand plan
stratégique donc là il y aura vraiment
les lignes directrices c'est newsday le
schéma de développement
l'espace régional on y reviendra très
vite ensuite
à côté de ceux d'air qui est juste si
vous voulez une ligne de conduite qui
n'est pas du tout contraignantes
j'ai un plan de secteur là c'est
vraiment un schéma de ce que l'on doit
faire au niveau des différents
territoires dans le secteur et les
terrains qui peuvent être bâties les
terrains qui doivent être conservés à
vocation agricole les terrains paysages
et les réserves naturelles les
territoires voulait une exploitation
industrielle donc le plan du secteur
ça c'est vraiment un outil important
parce que là c'est contraignant nous ne
pouvons pas faire soul si vous voulez
construire une maison en plein milieu
des champs parce que vous trouvez ça
joli le plan de secteur dit que ce n'est
pas possible la bière ça ne sera pas
possible
alors bien sûr il ya une foule de
dérogations mais canberra pas ici donc
alors concernant la commune
on va avoir une déclinaison solidaire et
de ce plan de secteur au niveau la
commune on aura ces deux schémas de
structures communales qui est en fait un
ministère s'il voulait adapter à la
commune on va aller très loin on va dire
voilà quelles sont les recommandations
qu'on pourrait faire pour les 5 10
prochaines années pour la commune en
terme d'aménagement du territoire ou
est-ce qu'on va construire quoi il est
enfin vous avez un plan communal
d'aménagement le pca qui est en fait un
mini camp de secteurs mais qui est
vraiment adapté à certaines portions de
la commune donc ça c'est les quatre les
cartes documents ou les cartes plans les
plus importantes aldana russe de
l'effort évidemment ça il faut connaître
parce que nous allons aborder ça dans
l'analyse du projet de la soirée voici
un autre tableau qui reprend les mêmes
informations mais qui voulaient organise
d'une autre manière
si si au niveau régional vous avez bien
sûr le secondaire et le plan de secteur
dont on vient de parler et puis en plus
du code wallon de l'aménagement du
territoire on a le règlement régional
d'urbanisme essor mais se focalisera pas
dessus alors la région wallonne le
niveau régional contrôle bien sûr les
permis d'urbanisme
plus une série de recours au niveau de
co au niveau communal donc l'orientation
notamment le plan stratégique le plan
général c'est le schéma de structure
il n'est donc pas le contraignant et à
côté de ce schéma de structure la
déclinaison de ce schéma de structure au
niveau communal c'est le pca les plans
communal d'aménagement
alors la loi communale c'est le
règlement communal d'urbanisme qui va
vraiment pour chaque commune aller très
loin en disant voilà le toit doit être
de cette couleur là les bric ne peuvent
pas être de cette couleur-là
l'orientation de la façade doit être
perpendiculaire ou parallèle à la rue
voilà des choses très précises qui
seront comprises dont le règlement
communal urbany évidemment au niveau la
commune on va contrôler les férus de
mots nous voulons construire une maison
vous allez voir faire la navette entre
les yeux et puis bon on a d'autres
secteurs le secteur privé qui va
intervenir et qui va me permettre la
mise en place de certains projets comme
le cas de la sqri mais ça nous
deviendrons ultérieure cette vidéo est
finie elle est assez complexe dans sa
matière
je vous proposerai revoir une seconde
fois si vous n'avez pas saisi toutes les
subtilités de ces matières il pourrait
en maîtrise étant donné qu'il s'agit
vraiment des bases pour comprendre les
problématiques d'aménagement du
territoire
je vous propose de passer sur ce qu
logis pour répondre au quizz
d'évaluation bonne fin de journée bon
travail à bientôt